thank you for joining us America Tina is
in Chicago how are you Tina
hi how are you better than I deserve
how can I help Dave my question is
actually regarding my parents I found
out a couple weeks ago that they are
basically broke they're in tremendous
debt they still have a mortgage on their
home quite a substantial mortgage on
their home and I'm trying to figure out
a way of advising them but what to do
where to go from here as far as getting
out of this debt selling their home
possibly maybe looking into a rental
somewhere
my mom had asked me about a reverse
mortgage I don't really know much about
that she is also considered bankruptcy
what are they what are they owned their
home okay let's see here they owe their
our first mortgage they owe a hundred
and sixty seven thousand eight hundred
twenty-five dollars they also have a
line of credit of 3145 are thirty
thousand $145 so they owe around a
little under two hundred on the home
what's it worth if they were to sell I
would say after selling they this is
being conservative about 275,000 so you
think of the house are going to market
for ran 300 right I think they could
probably list it for you know three
thirty after it's all said no this may
be coming away with two so what are the
debts if they got
okay they have probably around forty
four thousand dollars in credit card
debt mm-hmm okay what else that's it
they own their car they own their car
yes they have an older vehicle that's
been paid for one just one vehicle and
okay and what is their income okay
they're both retired he's seventy five
and a half she's 66 and a half their
income is basically Social Security his
Social Security her Social Security and
then they have an annuity that pays them
payments monthly which the total of all
three is three thousand seven hundred
and sixty three dollars how much is in
the unity the annuity they get payments
from I don't know a whole lot about this
but I saw a paperwork that said as of
the end of December of last year
the balance was sixty four thousand five
hundred and four dollars okay so
basically we have a hundred thousand
dollars in equity we have sixty four
thousand dollars and we have versus a
forty four thousand dollar debt and they
don't make enough income to pay their
house payment that's how they've gone
into critically their house payment is a
little over a thousand dollars Tom and I
pay both their house payments two
hundred thousand dollars worth of debt
cannot be supported on three thousand
dollars a month
correct that's how they got into credit
card debt and then they because credit
cards to live exactly exactly I figured
out they problem they have around forty
five hundred dollars of expenses they're
in the whole grand a month which is
twenty four thousand dollars a year is
going to be added to this credit card
debt until they go bankrupt if they
don't stop
they're in a death spiral mathematic
death spiral okay so the house is gone
you can't afford it right can't afford
it and no reverse mortgage will touch it
because reverse mortgage only makes a
loan of fifty five to sixty percent of
the value of the equity and that's they
don't have any equity if you put apply
that figure to it so besides that
reverse mortgages are horrible but aside
from that so we're selling the house and
I where did they live in Chicago we're
actually about an hour outside Chicago
in Indiana Crown Point Indiana good okay
so there's a chance we find them a
little condo for a hundred I've been
looking at that that's very hard to do I
know I know but it's just I mean here's
the thing opposed to getting another
mortgage on something they don't make
you money of a three thousand dollar
income they can't afford mortgage I mean
I you know and I got forty four thousand
dollars in credit card debt so I will
take their hundred equity and buy them
something if I can pay cash for it but
otherwise I'm gonna pay off their credit
card debt let them rent okay because I
do not want them back in a mortgage
again and you know and I hate to cash
out that's one asset this annuity
although it probably sucks yeah but if
you cash it out it's probably going to
have taxes on it hey jump online and get
with one of our smart investor pros and
unpack that annuity with them and see if
you can get up get them out of it if you
can get them out of it and clear the
credit card debt I would rather than be
in a paid-for house with almost no money
and be debt-free
credit cards and everything a paid-for
condo and I would liquidate that annuity
I would look today at that house I'd pay
off the credit card debt and I'd buy
something for cash with what the cash is
left and try to leave $10,000 in an
emergency fund and there are a hundred
percent broke with a paid for condo of
some kind and you know $2,000 a month
income to live on and they make it out
on that okay so you you do think they
should get rid of it cash out this
annuity that's possibly that's why I
said you need to sit down with a smart
mr. pro I don't know what the
implications of that are
because without getting into
packing the entire annuity on the air
which I'm not going to do we've already
unpacked their entire situation on the
air so just sit down with somebody and
look at that that's a possibility but I
can just tell you a hundred percent they
can't afford this house there's no
scenario in the mathematics you gave me
here than where they afford this house
unless you guys write them a check for
you know a hundred thousand bucks or
something if you got an extra hundred
grand laying around maybe they keep
their house you pay off the credit card
debts you pay down the mortgage you pay
off that second mortgage maybe they can
make it on the first mortgage but unless
you've got a hundred grand you can throw
at this they don't keep this house it's
just that they've already spent on the
money because basically that they were
just they were asleep at the wheel
financially and the credit card debt is
not because they were irresponsible it's
because they had a burn rate above their
income and they've been covering the
burn rate for existence that's what's
going on here mathematically it's so
hard to work through these things though
the Catena because it's just so
emotional you love your parents and you
wanted good stuff for them just like you
love your kids and you want good stuff
for them and the sad story is unless
somebody's got some money to throw at
this there's not gonna be a a really
super wonderful fireworks going off
financial happy ending to this it's
gonna be a struggle all the way through
because of their ages and their incomes
and that's where they are so um that's
the thing hey thanks for the call guys
did you know if you invest $100 a month
from age 30 to age 70 you're gonna have
around a million dollars in your mutual
funds in your 401k a hundred dollars
some of you spend that at freaking Taco
Bell a hundred dollars and you don't
have to
have this phone call with your daughter
that this lady just called how much of a
hundred thousand dollars how much it
would change that situation a 100
thousand one tenth of that how much it
would change that whole situation I'm
just talking about it probably wouldn't
have gotten in a couple of these things
but they you know you cannot spend all
you make all your life and end up
anywhere except dependent on social
insecurity it's tough to live on social
insecurity it's not enough money it was
never intended to be a retirement plan
it was intended to be a supplement to
retirement plan and when you don't have
a retirement plan that your whole
retirement plan and your on the output
budget it's not good y'all that's such a
sad situation that any spacing which
your mom and dad it breaks your heart
and that's where Tina is and she kind of
like she said she just discovered this
so they've kind of from their shame have
hidden it all these years
this is the Dave Ramsey show